e arrivato il giorno è arrivato il
giorno che tutti e dico tutti ma tu papà
anche vostra nonna giorno che tutti
stavano aspettando il sequel di sixty
seconds oggi ragazzi giochiamo adesso
devo far entrare la gente si taglia da
tutti ragazzi questo video sono felice
io ci siamo su sixty per sex ve lo dico
come se fosse il messia che non sono
però si parsec sarebbe il continuo di
sixty seconds hanno fatto sixty seconds
2 è ambientato nello spazio ed è una
figata pazzesca a vedersi poi non so
come allora posso cambiare la lingua ma
non c'e l'italiano va a cagare sa perché
vabbè tradurremo tradurremo let's go a
fossò posso scegliere il personaggio
rilling tradurvi quindi scusate se
faccio un po schifo però ci prova
allerta apocalisse nucleare imminente
ordine di esecuzione 1961 nuovo
protocollo iniziato i cittadini
astronauti si preparino per l'impatto
nucleare let's go che bello non vedo
l'ora legale bellissimo si dice
consapevole vedere il seguito astro city
slim cittadini spaziali credo che siamo
dispersi nello spazio cioè della
versione una figata incredibile ci ha
aspettato momento da una vita a posso
muovermi a perché dovrà accogliere gli
oggetti ok ati polsi se ok però come si
sa come si raccolgono le cose perché
questa urla al telefono
quanti problemi quanto figo dove si sta
raccogliendo sto facendo schifo non sto
capendo dove dove devo raccogliere lo
vedo le metto alla zuppa lo abbiamo
preso dovremo prendere dell'acqua roba
lamentoni va bene l'acqua si può
prendere non solo zuppa a questo
tutorial grazie a dio perché sono
veramente faccio schifo
beh sappiamo che ci stiamo imbarcando
con gente di un certo livello
tu lo shuttle let's go trova a son
crafting risorse quindi vi sono sempre
risorse per captare le cose va bene vai
la crew mei trova un compagno di cella
va questo che mi sembra un genio
attenzione adesso sta arrivando
l'impatto graduale vere wever you can l
ok ai 60 secondi va bene adesso devo
gravare tutto devo fare come quando
faccio su youtube
a fare il moneygram abbiamo 60 secondi
precisi barcaccia vacca cos'è sta roba
una batteria vai butta la butta non
sapendo come come ci si sopravvive
io prendo cose un po a caso quindi va
bene ma gli altri compagni di cella mi
servono a qualcosa o no perché se non li
prendo raga io l'acqua non la sto
trovando comunque non so se sono io
scemo e soprattutto 2000 tv calciava
calice una pala una palla nello spazio a
cosa mi serve
tu che urli al telefono vieni qua ti
prendo io
la cosa per captare ok manca pochissimo
pensare che se non entro in tempo poi mi
schiaccia
ci sono le figaro
ho preso un botto dirò no va bene ha
quindi la terra è distrutta
completamente la nostra tam in cella è
distrutta siamo gli unici superstiti
l'universo bene che figate incredibile
dai dai file partiamo che vedevo io
voglio vedere le mie skill anni passati
giocata su sixty seconds
voglio vedere le mie skill ecco che sta
un po il gioco che riassume come come
vivere da soli quando sono andato a
vivere da solo tre anni fa a milano
stessa roba
ecco allora siamo io che mi chiamo ddd
di dawkins poi c'è il baby bronco cosa
vuol dire per i prof
senti branco calmiamoci qua e tu sei
megan man che sembra il nome di un
supereroe ma non lo è e tu sei tomtom
son va bene
vabbè ragazzi allora sembrava tutto
carino qua c'è molto piu figo del del
bunker di sixty seconds crafting
all'aver volo che ha quindi perciò posso
causare le cose bellissime sto male
questi sono queste conta giorni a posto
razionare le cose avendo non so come si
giorno diverso la sexy secolo è molto
più figo c'è molta più roba da fare
quindi non lo so va bene io sto bevendo
del buon caffè questo stava ammiccando
perché vuole demon armi probabilmente
però non gliela do ei astro compiuta a
questo è il sistema di bordo bene come
si proseguono i giorni end of the day
no 3d ma devo fare delle cose prima che
finisca il giorno questo fare trova un
appropriato punto di atterraggio quindi
possiamo salvarci atterrandolo qualche
parte fighissimo a devo scegliere un
attributo o intelligenza no agilità sono
agile va bene posso decidere a chi dare
la zuppa cose non la do a nessuno
let's go non lo so come andrà a finire
però va beh non c'è l'acqua ha detto che
non c'è l'acqua rispetto a sixty seconds
squadra l'acqua non ci deve preoccupare
bevono solo caffè ricordati di razionare
il cibo
a meno che tu non voglia mangiarti uno
dei tuoi compagni di viaggio h stavo
scherzando che simpatico suo computer
chi controllerà relazioni ogni giorno
devo decidere io chi le controlla che
controllava la megane perché vecchia non
se le mangia lei son convinto mista di
fidata c'è ma poi possiamo sopravvivere
anche più di 99 giorni tante lunga una
partita di sto gioco scusate il giorno 3
ragazzi il giorno 3 nello spazio
lei contro la resa o che nello news cafè
ci siamo scontrati contro la navicella
che aveva delle del cibo quindi usiamo
va bene sono qui abbiamo preso altre due
di zuppa fantastico fighissimo ma io non
ho capito quindi adesso ne ho dieci
hanno più di nove non posso averne qua
c'è un altro scaffale cose che ci metti
i poster di raoul bova
va bene c'è una batteria automi cache o
prezzo cosa mi serve una batteria
atomica va beh va beh direi che possiamo
andare avanti
oggi è stata una giornata molto
produttiva let's go quattro giorni che
non mangiano questi è a proposito di
cibo c'è qualche problema carta oggetti
la zuppa noi sono tante grazie ricicla
mi dà 10 minerali ma cosa vi serve è una
cosa mi serve sta roba
no no no va bene così l'upgrade a posso
fare l'upgrade a bene upgrade chiamo la
tuta so cosa mi servono
ho gridato la tuta va bene tutta più uno
cosa che cosa amico e spedirlo a cosa mi
serve non siamo ancora come si esce di
qua allora c'è un malfunzionamento di
odore va bene cosa usiamo nastro adesivo
che non ho non fare niente usiamo la
zuppa usiamo land book per riparare la
faccenda vediamo se funziona il ripa
raggio let's go fichissime è fatto
veramente bene porca vacca cosa che è
successo ha praticamente c'era il cera
il filtro anti odore perché possiamo e
lo aggiustato quindi let's go toma fame
baby a fama un buon tipo così può
chiamarsi baby ha fame hanno tutti fame
tranne
no non tutti fanno e basta ora facciamo
che tutte magnano va bene anzi non
bagnano tutti domani non oggi preferisce
avere un momento per te stesso no voglio
stare con i miei amici
let's go non mangiate oggi mangiate
domani mangio io oggi allora non so bene
cosa sia questo ma mi sa che è arrivato
un messaggio arcano kim che monitori le
comunicazioni e lo faccio io faccio io
bisogna meno cioè io faccio qualcosa
meno sono senso non mangiate neanche
oggi mangiate domani non li schiacciano
tutti primo contatto
non siamo soli in questo universo i
segnali che abbiamo intercettato sono
stati decriptati e sono trasmissioni
aliena va bene quindi abbiamo
intercettato segnali ci sono degli
alieni che tra un po incontreremo quindi
sono cavoli nostri nel mentre mangiamo
perché stiamo morendo di fame e andando
a tutti quanti
giorno 8 che ho appena dato da mangiare
come fate ad avere fame sono successe
tante cose tecniche che non saprei
tradurre prove
comunque mi ha dato una batteria
termonucleare va bene cosa mi serve
cosa che è successo abbiamo attivato un
protocollo hicks per sbaglio fantastico
dei deficienti le conseguenze di
iniziare un protocollo saranno molto
severe usa ha dato a skille fa qualcosa
capitano va bene usa i pesi cosa mi
interessa cosa vuol dire parte il fatto
che non ho capito se stanno morendo di
fame o cosa cosa rosa cosa ho letto hai
provato a usare la forza il peso era la
forza mente ma non sei stato in grado di
stoppare protocollo hicks un virus di
influenza mutata e stato rilasciato
attraverso i condotti di ventilazione
del t ha beccato immediatamente ottimo
giorno 14 cosa sta facendo questo o mio
dio dove sono finito c'è la tipa mia è
morta dove ma io posso visitare le cose
ma come lo è di melo prima più posso
visitare i posti a cavolo ma di file e
le spedizioni io sono già morta vabbè
andiamo la baby bronco vai di bronco
no è morto e nonostante questo continuo
a fissarmi 9 nov e morta pure mega ma
porca a caso rimasto io e quell'altro
che è uscito prima che non so dove sia
finito però ok ma faccio mangiare la mia
perché sennò siamo messi malissimo e poi
devo vedere cosa succede ma se non
arriva nessuna darci una mano solo nel
siamo nella cacca
la mia è morto l'altro gli stili fame
porca h
se fosse resistito stanotte avrebbe
avuto due di zuppe no no sono morti
tutti 35 giorni che per tipo sixty
seconds non è neanche male sixty parks
ex non lo so quindi ragazzi questa era
la prima partita disse xd parsa è andata
malissimo per non sapere come giocare o
come fare qualsiasi cosa è molto più ma
tanto più incasinato di sixty seconds
c'è proprio un botto di nuovo in più
però è fighissimo cos'altro ragazzi se
vi piace tanto mi piace anche ricerca
per tiziana se non sono questi dischetti
ci vediamo allora possiamo video
beh ragazzi
[Musica]
ma